[INTRO MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
DR. VINCE VITALE:
The alternative
to fleeing from truth
is fighting for truth.
I was walking around
Oxford a few months ago.
And two guys walking
just ahead of me
were having a
spirited conversation
about how crazy they found
certain beliefs that they
disagreed with.
And one turned to
the other and said,
maybe the only solution
would be to shame them out
of their beliefs.
And then, the other guy turned,
and this is what he said.
I wrote it down.
He said, "Yes, that's
what we should do.
We should ridicule
them mercilessly
in the most insensitive
ways we can think of."
That's an exact quote.
And then, they turned, and they
swiped their faculty cards,
and walked into the University
of Oxford of Theoretical
Physics building.
These were probably scholars
at Oxford, a place that prides
itself on intellectual freedom.
And the exchange of ideas and
merciless, insensitive ridicule
was the best that
they can come up
with for how we should
resolve disagreements.
I found myself wondering
how many beliefs they
held in theoretical
physics that one day will
be considered ridiculous.
How does someone
get to this point?
get to the point
where merciless ridicule seems
like the best way forward?
I think it's because you come to
see truth as greater than love.
If truth is greater than
love, then you fight.
Then, the pursuit
of truth justifies
whatever means necessary,
whether the means of Oxford
academics or the
means of terrorists.
The alternative is that
love is greater than truth.
Then, you flee.
You flee from the
dangers of truth,
and accept every
belief, no matter
how incoherent because at least
that's better than starting
yourself on a trajectory
that, ultimately,
is going to lead to intolerance,
extremism, and violence.
The truth gets sacrificed
at the altar of love,
or love gets sacrificed
at the altar of truth.
Either truth is
greater than love,
or love is greater than truth.
Fight or flee.
This is the cultural ultimatum
that we're living in.
What's your choice?
And I don't think it's
getting any better.
I had a graphic here
of a representation
of our increasing political
polarization in this country.
And when you see the difference
between 1994 and 2004,
it's very minimal in terms
of our political values.
And then, when you
see the widening
of the gap between 2004
and 2014, it's huge.
92% of Republicans are to the
right of the median Democrat.
And 94% of Democrats are to the
left of the median Republican.
We're not close enough
to talk to each other.
And so, from that
distance, all you can do
is either ignore each other,
or shout at each other.
Once again, fight or flee.
What's your choice?
Maybe there's another way.
Hassan John was one of
my students last year.
He's an Anglican minister
from northern Nigeria.
And on the first day
of classes at lunch,
one of his fellow classmates
said to him, Hassan,
how do you manage to minister
in a context in which you're
viewed as the enemy?
We knew that Hassan
was from a region that
was terrorized by Boko Haram.
We found out only later that
he had been shot at twice
and that there was a
bounty on his head.
Hassan began to tell us a story
of how there came a point when
he had seen so many of
his brothers and sisters
murdered for their
faith that he started
a conversation with a known
gun dealer to acquire an AK47.
And he thought violence
was the only answer.
When he was in his home
trying to figure out
where to get the money
to acquire this gun,
a young girl ran by the
front door of his home
during school hours.
He stopped her, and he said,
why aren't you in school?
She said, my parents don't
have the money to pay.
He said, that's not right.
My church and I would like
to pay for your school fees.
Will you take me
to your parents?
And then, his stomach
knotted up as she walked him
across the clear dividing line
between the Christian section
of town and the Muslim
section of town.
He had assumed that this girl
was from a Christian home.
She was, in fact,
from a Muslim home.
But he had committed to
paying her school fees,
and so Hassan and his church
began to pay her school fees.
Then, he found out that
her brothers were also
not in school.
Then, he met another Muslim
child who wasn't in school,
and another, and another.
Today, there are
200 Muslim children
who are being educated
in church schools
by Hassan and his church.
Then Hassan thought
to himself, why are we
only helping the children?
He realized that the
women in his community
had a style of making clothes
that the Muslim women didn't
have.
And the Muslim women
had a style of cooking
that the Christian
women didn't have.
And now there are 160
Christian and Muslim women
who get together, and
share their expertise,
and befriend each other,
and bless each other.
Just before Hassan
came to Oxford,
some militant youths who
are involved in terrorism
showed up at his front door.
And he was scared.
He thought his
life was in danger.
He thought his family's
And they looked at him sternly,
and they said, why don't you
do anything for us?
You help the children.
You help the women.
Why don't you do
anything for us?
Militant youth engaged
in terrorism are showing
[? up at the ?] [? door ?] of
an Anglican pastor asking him
to incorporate them into
his mission strategy.
Absolutely unbelievable.
And here's my question.
Why did those youth
respond so positively?
After all, Hassan was
disagreeing with them
in a big way.
For starters, he was
saying that Jesus Christ
should be at the center
of their education.
He was also clearly saying that
we should love our enemies,
we should turn the
other cheek, and we
should pray for those
who persecute us,
things that would not have
been true in their world view.
But here's the thing.
Hassan's disagreement
with them was not
greater than his love for them.
His loving sacrifice for
them was the very content
of his disagreement with them.
He cut the link between
disagreement and devaluing
of the person because his
communication of truth
was one and the same as
his communication of love.
And that is the gospel.
That is the central
message of Christianity.
Jesus disagreed with us.
His very coming was an act
of disagreement with us.
A statement that we required
saving because our lives
disagreed so badly with what
He had intended for them.
But Jesus' coming was also his
greatest act of love for us.
His willingness to
suffer alongside us.
join us in our shame.
His willingness to lay
down His life for us.
The cross where Jesus died,
this symbol of Christianity.
It's a symbol of the perfect
intersection of love and truth.
Jesus's death is the
greatest expression
of God's disagreement with us.
And yet, simultaneously, it
is the greatest expression
of God's love for us.
Truth and love perfectly
united in a personal sacrifice.
Not truth is greater than love.
Not love is greater than truth.
But God is love.
And God is truth.
And therefore, truth is love.
In Jesus, truth equals love.
And therefore, I think
Jesus is uniquely positioned
to get us out of the cultural
ultimatum that we're stuck in.
Fight or flee.
Authentic Christianity
rejects that ultimatum.
It refuses to let
disagreement lead
to the devaluing of the other.
It refuses to choose
between truth and love
because, according to Jesus,
and in the person of Jesus,
and in His sacrifice, truth
and love are one in the same.
On one of his last
Sunday's with us in Oxford,
our pastor interviewed Hassan.
And his first question was, he
asked Hassan, is it worth it?
And Hassan had this, sort of,
quizzical look on his face
because the answer
was so obvious to him.
And he said, of course.
And then, our
pastor asked Hassan
if he had any parting
words for us as a church.
And he said that he did.
And then he said,
I beg you, do not
compromise here in
the West on the faith
that we, in Africa,
are dying for.
Do not compromise here
in the West on the faith
that we, in Africa,
are dying for.
And I personally have
to keep reminding myself
that this is not
extraordinary Christianity.
This is just the simple
message of Jesus.
Truth that is of love,
love that is truth.
Laying down your life in
order to communicate the truth
to others.
Who are you laying
down your life for?
Every Christian needs to be
able to answer that question.
How often is our disagreement
with others our very act
of giving our lives for them?
What would that look
like in our context?
What would it look
like for us to disagree
with people with
such generosity,
and such love, and
such personal sacrifice
that the people we're
disagreeing with
would show up on
our front doorstep,
as they did with Hassan,
asking for us to act
on our disagreement with them?
Who do you disagree
with passionately?
Who's your enemy?
I wonder if someone just
jumped into your mind
as I asked those questions.
Are you fighting them?
Are you fleeing from them?
Or are you making a
personal sacrifice for them?
What would it look like
to communicate truth
to those we disagree with
through an act of radical love
and personal sacrifice?
That is the question.
I don't think that's
an easy question.
But that is the question
that Hassan figured out
how to answer in his context.
And I think we will
live in brokenness
until we can figure
out how to answer
that question in our context.
We're being told that we
live in a post truth society
that, truth is dead.
I don't think that
truth is dead.
But I do think that truth died.
2000 years ago on a wooden
cross, the truth was stretched,
the truth was twisted,
and it was bent.
The truth hurt, and
the truth was buried.
Love and truth is at the central
message of the Christian faith.
Love and truth find their
unity and their power
in personal sacrifice.
And there's only one God who
has sacrificed himself for us.
And that's the God that
I commend to you today.
[INAUDIBLE] brief word
of prayer with me.
God, I thank you that I can
come to you with such confidence
that you are both
love and truth.
I thank you that when you
came and made a sacrifice
that you didn't have to make.
You told me the
truth about myself.
You convinced me of
the evil in my heart
because people just
like me killed you.
And yet, simultaneously,
you convinced me
of your love for me
because you showed me
that there was nothing
that you wouldn't give,
even your very
life, that I might
be in friendship
and relationship
with you for all eternity.
And God, if that vision
of love and truth
perfectly intersecting in
perfect unity that is true
only in you, if there's anyone
in this room who doesn't know
that possibility, who has
felt like they need to choose,
I pray that today
would be a day where
that vision of who you are,
perfect love and perfect truth,
would settle deep
within our souls
and would bring transformation.
I trust you for that.
In Jesus' name, amen.
[APPLAUSE]
RAVI ZACHARIAS:
Thank you, Vince.
When I stand up before
you, I feel a little bit
like a man who owned a
business on fortune telling
and had a few
hundred palm readers.
And he would gather them all
together and said to them,
I hate to give you
this news, but we're
going to have to let
about half of you go.
He said, but then again, you all
probably knew that was coming.
[LAUGHING]
And so when I stand up in
front of a Google audience,
I wonder if there's
anything I can
say that you don't already
know, that you've either
heard or read somewhere.
I mean, you're an
amazing group of people.
A company starting off with
a proper name that turns
into a verb across the globe.
I remember being picked
up in Delhi late one night
by the hotel limousine.
And as he was driving
me, I was quite tired.
You know, when you land
after a day's journey,
you look like your
passport picture.
[LAUGHING]
And he was driving
me to the airport.
And then, he told me how
many books I had written.
I said, how do you know that?
He said, before I came,
I Googled your name, sir.
[LAUGHING]
And so here's a limousine
driver quoting you
guys thousands of
miles away using
a word that has now
become synonymous
with actionable intelligence.
So you are certainly
one of the prime movers
of turning thought into action.
But I will always remember
what I heard one speaker say.
I cannot remember where it
was, but I heard him say it.
He said, you may
have a smartphone,
but that is no guarantee
that it is a wise phone.
All kinds of access
to information
does not guarantee
how we ought to live.
It only tells us
how we can live.
When you put capacity,
and possibility, and ideas
within reach, if you have
not trained the character
to use that capacity,
all you end up doing
is putting the reach for
some very, very heinous ends
in the hands of a
person who does not
know what to do with
that except to break it.
That's a sobering
thought for you.
It's a very sobering thought
for a person like me.
Where do you go to find wisdom?
It was Aldous Huxley
writing in the '40s who
made the comment I want this
world not to have meaning.
In his book "Ends and Means,"
"I want this world not
to have meaning, because a
meaningless world, said he,
gives me the freedom to
my own sexual proclivities
and my political ambitions."
A meaningless world
puts at my disposal
the possibility of
all that I want to do
without any moral boundaries.
You know, it was Andrew
Fletcher, the 18th century
political activist
from Scotland,
who said, let me write
the songs of a nation.
I don't care who
writes its laws.
Let me write the
songs of a nation.
I don't care who
writes its laws,
because knowledge is
a deadly friend when
no one sets the rules.
And the rock group said, and
the fate of all mankind, I see,
is in the hands of fools.
Confusion will be my
epitaph as I crawl
a cracked and broken path.
If we make it, we can
all sit back and laugh.
But I'm afraid tomorrow
I'll be crying.
You see, once upon a time, you
had to go to places in order
to become wrongheaded.
Now those places come to
you and dangle on your hip,
and have the capacity
to take young minds
and pervert them so
quickly and so soon
that I think you and I both have
an extraordinary responsibility
to this generation.
How do we give them
what they can do?
And where do they go to find
out what they ought to do?
Because true freedom is
really not the liberty
to do whatever we want but the
strength to do what we ought.
Think of it this way.
Dr. Martin Luther King,
Jr., in the reception
of his Nobel Prize, made
an extraordinary speech.
And his closing line said this.
He started off by
saying, "I refuse
to believe that
man is mere flotsam
and jetsam in a river of life.
I refuse to believe
that we are so bound
to the starless
of racism and war
that the bright daybreak
of peace and brotherhood
will not become a reality.
I refuse all these things."
And then he ended
by saying this.
"I believe unarmed truth
and unconditional love
will have the final
word in reality."
Imagine that.
I believe that unarmed
truth and unconditional love
will have the final
word in reality.
Now, our entire educational
system is based on naturalism.
The metaphysical extrapolations
of a materialistic world view.
But if unarmed truth
and unconditional love
will have to have the
final word in reality,
that does not come from
scientific imperatives.
Those are philosophical, indeed
metaphysical, or, if you would,
spiritual latitudes.
An unarmed truth and
unconditional love
will have the final
day in reality.
And if that doesn't, what you
end up is the young man being
put into a plane, and
shipped across 10,000 miles,
and comes home as a physical
zombie to be held in the arms
of his parents who are glad
just to be able to hold him,
even though he
cannot even respond.
You're living in a world
of immense possibilities.
And men and women like you have
that incredible responsibility
of how you're going
to guide our young,
and how you're
going to determine
that truth and love will have
the final word in reality.
Otherwise, the victory
will be Pyrrhic,
where the vanquished has
gained more than the victor.
And so I bring to you this
question in a very simple way
within a few minutes.
It all has to do with
this very basic question.
In our book, "Jesus
Among Secular Gods,"
we deal with humanism, and
existentialism, and naturalism,
and evolutionism,
and all of that.
And we give the
Christian alternatives.
What is the alternative
that Jesus Christ really
gives to you and me?
And I have to say this.
I do not know of any
answers that anybody
gets that correspond more
to reality as we live it out
and put together a
coherent worldview
as the teachings of Jesus
did going back 2,000 years
and what he taught.
And prior to that,
of course, building
on the shoulders of the
prophets and all who
had spoken before him.
And the question is this.
What does it mean to be human?
That's the question
from where we start.
What does it mean to be human?
What is it that you
essentially represent?
Not what you
existentially may crave,
but what is it that you
essentially represent?
Who you are in your
innermost being.
In our search for
identity today,
which is a very real
search, if we do not
know who we are in our essence,
then the Chestertonian warning
is true that there are many,
many angles at which you
can fall, and only one angle at
which you can stand straight.
And GK Chesterton went on to
say the tragedy of disbelieving
in God is not that a person
ends up believing in nothing.
Alas, it is much worse.
That person may end up
believing in anything.
A young student of
Harvard made this comment
to Kelly Monroe [? Kohlberg ?]
in a book, the "Finding God
at Harvard."
He said this.
"I am allowed to
believe anything here,
so long as I don't
claim it to be true."
That is ironic, because
the very motto of Harvard
is veritas, which means the
imperative for the reason
for their existence,
something that you can never
affirm in your life.
How ironic.
How contradictory
has life begun.
I want to give you four
very quick answers to this.
I've dealt with it
more extensively.
And I believe in one of
the chapters of book,
I deal with this.
And it is this.
But let me go back this way.
In the year 2000, the
former Soviet Union
released its
political prisoners.
One of them is a man by the name
of Andreas Thomas, a Hungarian,
who had been incarcerated
by them for 55 years.
Most of the time, in
solitary confinement.
They believed he'd
gone insane, and they
were going to do away with him.
But Andreas Thomas showed
moments and flashes
of reality, which made
them think maybe he
was just medically ill.
So a Hungarian psychiatrist
offered to come and treat him,
and he did.
And as he walked away
from the room, he said,
he is not insane.
You have driven him to the
point of near insanity.
Give him back to us.
We will make him well again.
So he's put into a wheelchair.
And Andreas Thomas
is being wheeled out.
And as he's being wheeled out,
he makes his first request.
He was speaking an
old Hungarian dialect.
He'd gone to prison
when he was 20.
He was now 75.
And he asked, made
his first request,
he wanted to see a mirror.
He had not seen his
face in 55 years.
So there you are the
vibrancy of youth and strong.
And over half a
century later, you're
going to look at your
face for the first time.
And as soon as he
looked at his face,
he could barely stand it
for more than a moment.
Turned the mirror down,
put his face in his hands,
and sobbed uncontrollably.
It destroyed him.
He had never remembered what
he had looked like, and longed
for the day when he was
a mere 20 to see what he
was in the prime of his youth.
Is there a mirror for the soul?
Is there a mirror
for our essence?
The bible says, yes, there is.
And I give you
four quick answers.
Number one, that we have a
creator, which means life
has a purpose.
Every time you read
a book, you know
there's an author to that book.
There is a writer.
There is an intent.
There is a storyline.
And that creator has revealed
his plan for us and given to us
two things.
Intrinsic worth and
reflective splendor.
How do we know what
that intrinsic worth is?
There are two
amazing conversations
Jesus has in the gospel of
Mark in Mark chapter 12.
The first one comes to him
and is trying to pit politics
against politics.
And he says to him, is it all
right to pay taxes to Caesar?
And how desperately we
wish Jesus had said no.
[LAUGHING]
But Jesus said, do
you have a coin?
And the man said, yes.
He said, give it to me.
And he looked at the coin,
and looked at the man,
And He said, whose image
do you see on this?
And the man said, Caesar.
Jesus said give to Caesar
that which belongs to Caesar,
and give to God that
which belongs to God.
The man should have had
a follow-up question.
The follow-up question should
have been, what belongs to God?
And Jesus would have said,
whose image is on you?
You belong to God.
It's not surprising that
he refers to his body
as the temple--
as the temple of the living
God where you commune with him.
It's a tent.
It's not anything of
permanence, but it is a shelter.
It is a place where
you have communion.
No other world view gives you
that description of imago dei.
You are not God.
There is a Hindi song, which we
used to sing when I was young.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
I am not God, nor
am I the devil.
You can say what you will.
I am a human being.
I'm a human being.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
I'm not God.
I'm not Satan.
The world, you can
choose what you will.
I have concluded I
am a human being.
And Jesus states that to
the highest possible level,
you're not God.
You're not human.
But you are made
in the image of God
to be self-determining and
have moral reasoning capacity.
That's the difference.
We have moral
reasoning capacity.
That's what made America very
unique in the experimentation
of political theory.
It was not reasoning alone,
which the French philosophes
and the German philosophers
and all talked about reasoning,
and all the way from man is
the measure of all things,
going back to the Greek thinkers
and coming through Descartes
and so on, where just
because you doubt,
therefore you know
that you exist.
Moral reasoning-- the
sense of is an oughtness--
is what drove the
American dream.
Gertrude Himmelfarb, professor
of Columbia University,
in her book "The
Roads to Modernity"
has a whole chapter on
the evangelical awakening.
Of all people, a
philosopher like
that talking about the impact
of the Wesleyan meetings
to awaken England to the
moral reasoning capacity
that we have.
Intrinsic worth.
And then, the second
conversation Jesus
has in the same chapter is
the man trying to set religion
against religion,
law against law,
not politics against religion.
He says, what's the
greatest commandment?
See, Moses gives 613.
Isaiah reduced them to 11.
David to 15.
Micah to 3.
Do justice, love mercy, and
walk humbly before your God.
Jesus could have
reduced it to one.
He didn't.
He said, you know what the
greatest commandment is?
To love the Lord your God
with all your heart, and all
your soul, and all your
mind, and all your strength,
and to love your
neighbor as yourself.
He said, on these
two commandments
hang all of the laws
of the prophets.
Because of the first,
the second follows.
Without the first, the second is
with their feet firmly planted
in mid-air.
I cannot violate you because you
are made in the image of God.
And out of all of the 613 laws,
my Lord reduced it to two.
To love him, and to
love [INAUDIBLE]..
I have no right to violate
you or, in any way,
to dismember who you are.
That's why we are
called individuals.
We are indivisible.
There is that composite
reality to your life and mine.
Intrinsic worth and
reflective splendor.
The reflective
splendor being this.
That you have an
individual relationship
in this cosmic community.
I was gone for about four
months through many countries.
Got home last week, and
spent this last five, six
days at home.
They were beautiful.
To know that I was having
dinner with my wife every night,
that's a huge blessing.
And then, to know that the
grandkids could come and open
the door without even knocking.
Nice to see you, Papa.
We celebrated a birthday.
When I get back on
Friday, I'll have
to go through a torturous
one-hour ballet recital of two
four-year-old grandkids.
[LAUGHING]
And they want to make sure
I'm coming back for that.
You see, in this world of so
many people we love and know,
there's a particularity
to relationships,
which defines who you and I are
in the microcosm of a family.
My son went to Taylor
University, Indiana.
In 2006, they had a
horrible accident there.
And all of them were
smashed to death
in a van coming home from a
weekend of doing some work.
And as the funerals
were held, there
was only one gal
whose life was spared.
Her name was Laura Van Ryn.
And so the Van Ryn family came
and stood by her bedside day
after day, week after week.
But as she began to
gain her composure,
her boyfriend said
something's not right.
That's not Laura.
They said, what do you
mean that's not Laura?
She's all mangled.
She'll come to it.
He said, no, that's not Laura.
The answers are not
making any sense,
but they seem to be
making sense to her.
Finally, one day
she opened her eyes.
And she said, why do you
all keep calling me Laura?
My name is Whitney.
I'm not Laura.
So the father, the Van
Ryn dad, gets on the phone
and calls the office.
Was there a girl by the
name of Whitney in the van?
Said, yes, there
was a Whitney Cerak.
They said, we think we've
got Whitney in the bed here.
That's not Laura.
They called the coroner.
Have you done a DNA
test after the deaths?
No.
He instantly lost his job.
They had the wrong
name of the person.
And who they had
buried as Whitney Cerak
was actually Laura Van Ryn.
And the girl they thought
was Laura in the bed
was actually Whitney Sarack.
So one comes back to
change the grave marker.
And the other goes home
thinking they had their daughter
but didn't.
You see, there is a
particularity to your life.
Only God is big enough
in a world of billions
of people to give you individual
worth and the individual access
to a relationship.
Only God is big enough for
that in the created order.
I will just mention two others,
and then [INAUDIBLE] third.
The second is the incarnation
from creation to incarnation.
Third is transformation.
And fourth is consummation.
And let me just talk
about the incarnation
and miss the other two
because time has run out.
In the incarnation
of Jesus Christ,
we see the absoluteness
of the moral law
and the supremacy of love.
The absoluteness of the moral
law and the supremacy of love.
And in that, the
absoluteness of the moral law
and the supremacy
of love, you go
through any kinds of humanism.
Evolutionary humanism,
behavioral humanism,
existential humanism, pragmatic
humanism, Marxist humanism,
existential humanism,
cultural humanism.
You take all the six or seven
types of various humanisms.
All of them struggle
with these two.
Where do we find the
absolute moral law?
How do we find and
come to the conclusion
of the supremacy of love?
My daughter, who works with
the broken of this world,
rescuing women from the
sex trafficking industry
and children with AIDS, she
has called me this morning
from Atlanta.
She said, Dad, I have to give
a talk on pain and suffering,
and how meaning can
come out of that.
Can we talk for a little while?
It was early in the morning.
She had forgotten I
was on California time.
And so anyway, we
talked about it.
And I said to her in a very
simple verse, God displayed
for you and me in the
brokenness on the cross
how the redemptive work of God
went on in your life and mine.
So you see, he moves
us from creation
to the incarnation to the key
point here that transformation.
What is desperately
needed in this world,
is a transformed heart
and a transformed will,
and different hungers
that God alone
is big enough to give
within your heart and mind.
I am a testimony to
it, and I will close
with a simple illustration.
I was 17 years old
growing up in India.
India is a country of incredible
pressure in academics.
You don't just have to pass.
You have to come at
the top of the class.
And if you are not
going to make it,
you're going to bring
shame to the family.
The highest number of
suicides take place
in India within a week
after the results are
published in the newspapers.
They are jumping off buildings.
They're killing themselves.
They have words for
that kind of thing.
I remember being called
that kind of word
periodically by my dad
when I wasn't making it
till, finally, it drove
me to a bed of suicide.
And I said, I'm not
going to make it
in my father's estimation.
And at the age of 17, a
bible was brought to me.
I didn't own a bible.
I'd never opened a bible.
I never cared for it.
And to read in
that gospel story,
Jesus said because I
live, you also shall live.
And making my commitment
in all that blurred way,
I'll never forget the
words of the doctor
when he came to discharge me.
He looked at me, and he said
beta, which is Hindi for son.
Beta, I have given
you back your life,
but I cannot make
you want to live.
I've given you back your life,
but I cannot make you want
to live.
I said, doctor, that's
been taken care of already.
And so I say to you,
with all of your success,
with all of the
intellectual prowess,
and of the ability, what are you
really living for that's worth
giving your entire life for?
And what Christ says is when
he changes your heart and mind,
in that transformation
process, he
makes us live for the very
purpose God has made us.
Think of this for a moment.
Can you go to the
automobile manufacturer
and tell them you are
creating a weapon?
You're creating a weapon.
You are involved
in killing people
on the streets of London,
on the streets of Paris,
because you're making this
automobile as a weapon.
They would look at
you and say, that's
not what we intend this for.
Purpose, even in inanimate
objects, is so critical.
How much more is
it for you and me?
A man who's no friend
to the Christian, who
is an avowed atheist
and chooses to live
a life without boundaries,
name is Matthew Parris.
He writes in the British
newspapers regularly.
He wrote an article
some time back
which is absolutely astounding.
He goes to Africa to
see the work of NGOs.
And he saw a small group
of Christians in Malawi.
He was raised in Malawi.
He saw what these Christians
living a simple life
had accomplished in Malawi.
He wrote a brilliant,
brilliant article.
And I wish I had the time
to read all of it to you.
But let me just leave
the last two paragraphs.
There's long been a fashion
among Western academics
sociologists for placing tribal
value systems within a ring
fence.
Beyond critiques founded in
[? theirs ?] and, therefore,
the best for them.
Authentic and intrinsically
of equal worth to us.
I simply don't
follow this anymore.
I observe that the tribal belief
is no more peaceable than ours,
and that it actually
suppresses individuality.
People think
collectively this feeds
into the big man and gangster
politics of the African city.
The exaggerated respect
for the swaggering leader
and the literal
inability to understand
the whole idea of the loyal
opposition, anxiety, fear
of spirits of ancestors,
of nature in the wild,
strikes deep into
the whole structure
of rural African thought.
But great weight grinds down
upon the spirit of the people.
Christianity, with its teaching
of a direct, personal, two-way
link between the individual
and God unmediated
by the collective
and unsubordinate
to any other human
being, smashes
straight through the
philosophical spiritual
framework I've just described.
Those who want
Africa to walk tall
amid 21st century global
competition must not
kid themselves that
providing the material means
or even the know-how
that accompanies
what we call development will
end up making the change.
A whole belief system
has to be supplanted.
And I'm afraid it has to
be supplanted by another.
Removing Christian evangelism
from the African equation
may leave the continent
at the mercy of a malign
fusion of Nike, the witch
doctor, the mobile phone,
and the machete.
There's only one thing I
disagree with him on this.
It's not just Africa.
It's the whole world.
The gospel of evangelism
that changes the heart
is the only message
we have where
I have seen in parts
of the world people who
are one time heading
to behead others
now kneeling at an altar
in humility, and grace,
and forgiveness.
That is the gospel story.
What does it mean to
be human from creation,
to the incarnation,
to transformation,
and consummation?
The bible gives us the
narrative very clearly.
That's why Augustine said,
you have made us for yourself.
And our hearts are
restless until they
find their rest in thee.
Thank you so much
for [INAUDIBLE]..
[APPLAUSE]